Hi, Mystery Recapped here. Today I am going to
explain an American action crime thriller film
called “Safe.” Spoilers ahead!
Watch out and take care!
In Nanjing, China lives a little girl named
Mei. She is a gifted mathematician who can
solve complicated mathematical problems in her
head. She also has a great memory and never
forgets any series of numbers she comes across.
One day, Mei is walking home with her friends
when a group of men abducts her. She is taken
to a Chinese mafia leader named Han. The digital
data of Han’s criminal enterprise is traceable,
hence he wants to use Mei as his personal mental
calculator who can memorize the data for him.
Initially, the little girl refuses to cooperate,
but when he threatens to kill her mother, she
agrees to do as told. Under the care of their
trusted gang member, Chang, Mei is brought to
New York where she is hidden as his daughter.
Somewhere Else in New Jersey, former cop and
cage fighter Luke is in an intense match with his
opponent. He has set the match up and is supposed
to lose. But he accidentally throws a punch at
his opponent and knocks him out into a coma.
The win angers the head of the Russian mafia,
Emile who lost millions of dollars on Luke.
Luke realizes that an angry gangster would
mean that his family is in trouble. He
rushes home but is too late because the
gangster's son Vassily has already killed his
pregnant wife. Luke is devastated by the death
and although he can fight, he doesn’t retaliate.
The thugs then promise to kill anyone with whom
he speaks to or makes contact. With nowhere and
no one to go to, Luck returns to his hometown,
New York. He starts living as a homeless person,
wandering around in the streets of Manhattan.
One year later, Mei is still working with the
gang. Chang takes her on a weekly round of the
streets in Chinatown. She memorizes the percentage
of net profit or loss every store faces. The store
owners are supposed to pay the gang a certain
amount of money according to the profit,
hence Mei is proven to be a useful asset
to them. Throughout her time working with
the gang, she has learned a lot about how
business works in the gangster world.
Somewhere else, Luke lives in a highly unorganized
homeless shelter. One night, he meets a man with
no shoes and severely infected feet. Out of
sympathy, he gives the man his new shoes.
But the next day, he wakes up to discover
that someone slit the poor guy’s throat
and stole his shoe overnight. Suffice to say
that Luke’s living conditions are poor.
Meanwhile, a lady working closely with Chang
approaches Mei in the middle of the night
and informs her of her mother’s death back in
China. It turns out that she was severely sick
and in hospital. The following day, the leader of
the gang Han comes to New York for the first time
since he sent Mei. He has come with a piece of
paper with a series of numbers on it. Mei is asked
to memorize the number which she does in less
than ten seconds. The numbers seem to be of great
importance because Han burns the piece of paper
to ashes so only Mei would know what they are.
After that, Chang takes her to the next location.
Mei is told that she will have to memorize the
second series of numbers when she reaches the
destination. Everything goes according to the plan
until they are attacked by the Russian mafia;
led by Emil, the gangster who killed Luke’s wife.
They are also after Mei because of the numbers she
has memorized. A shootout ensues where the Chinese
gangsters lose to the Russians who abduct Mei.
Somewhere else, Luke is having a bad day because
a passerby stole his breakfast money. While
trying to buy something, he bumps into his former
colleague in the police force. The man instantly
recognizes Luke and takes him to an abandoned
building with his fellow cops. Long back, Luke
debunked their corrupt ways of helping the local
gangsters. The cops are still furious at him for
getting them in trouble back then. They beat him
up and insult him but he doesn’t retaliate. In
the end, a cop hands Luke a gun, urging him to end
his own life. But Luke refuses and walks away.
At the same time, Mei is taken to the Russian gang
leader Emile who asks her about the numbers. She
soon finds out that the lady who told her about
her mother was helping Emil the entire time.
The lady also asks Mei to tell them the code,
but in turn, Mei claims that the woman is going to
die because she doesn’t know how business works.
Right after, the men shoot her dead since she is
no use to them anymore. Mei knows she will suffer
the same fate if she tells them the number, hence,
she keeps quiet. Just then, a corrupt cop and one
of Luke’s former colleagues, Captain Wolf, come
to the Russian hideout to catch the criminals.
However, he is not doing it for law, but on the
orders of the Chinese leader, Han. Emile calls the
Captain and offers him double the money than the
Chinese gangsters to get away from his hideout.
The corrupt captain accepts the deal and retreats.
By this time, Mei has run away from the hideout
without anyone seeing her. Both the Russians and
Chinese gangsters start looking for her, in hopes
of finding her before the other group does.
Mei eventually reaches the subway station where
Luke is about to end his life. He is seconds away
from jumping on the tracks when he locks eyes with
the scared little girl and stops himself. He also
notices the gangsters who killed his wife looking
for the little girl. To run away from them, she
gets on the subway but the gang gets a glimpse of
her and follows behind. Luke realizes something is
wrong and makes it his mission to save the girl.
He latches onto the subway and kills all the
Russians on his way. One of them recognizes
Luke as the guy they beat up a year ago. He is
surprised as to how someone so submissive can
defeat all their people in minutes. In the end,
he is also killed and Luke finally meets Mei.
But as soon as the subway stops, she runs away
with the crowd, mistaking Luke for one of the bad
guys. On his way to look for her, Luke overhears
a red alert code being relayed to all the cops.
He registers that the girl is also wanted by the
corrupt policemen who will definitely hand her to
the mafia. A few minutes in, two cops who beat
up Luke earlier find the girl and try to take
her away. Luke arrives at the right time and
knocks them out in an instant, proving that he
was staying quiet only because he wanted to. Mei
still doesn’t trust him but gets into a car with
him when the Russian mafia arrives. A high-speed
car chase ensues in the streets of Manhattan.
At last, Luke kills all the Russians, steals
their wallets, and takes Mei to a fancy hotel.
Somewhere else, the captain finds out that
Mei was taken by force, not by the mafia but
by Luke. He is in shock because Luke hasn’t been
involved in anything crime-related since he left
the police force. Meanwhile, after checking into
the hotel, Mei starts to trust Luke and tells him
about the numbers she memorized. On checking the
format of the numbers, he figures out that it is
the combination of a safe. Mei says she was
supposed to memorize a second number before
the Russians attacked, which means there are two
safes with something valuable in it, probably
being traded by the Chinese mafia. Just then,
Chang finds out Mei’s location using a tracking
device in her phone. He and his henchmen arrive
at the hotel and start a shootout. Chaos ensues
when people start to run for their lives.
Eventually, Luke gets into a fistfight with
the gangsters which causes him and Mei
to separate. Chang gets his hands on her
while Luke escapes before he is killed.
He knows that he cannot leave Mei alone and
is ready to do anything to get her back safe. So,
he calls the Russian leader Emile’s son Vassily
from a phone he stole earlier. Vassily is also
the guy who killed Luke’s wife a year ago. Luke
pretends to be their gang member and claims that
he has the number that everyone is looking for.
Vassily believes him and calls him to a casino
to deliver the said number. Somewhere else,
the city’s mayor calls the corrupt police captain
to his office to discuss all the shootings. It
turns out that he and his boyfriend Alex are also
just as corrupt as the others. The mayor reveals
that Luke wasn’t a normal cop. In fact, he was
a CIA agent, loaned to the police force after
9/11. When he was in the police force, he and his
former partner Alex assassinated several crime
bosses in an effort to impose order. However,
Luke had to quit after exposing the corrupt ways
of the Captain and his squad. Alex stayed and
seduced the mayor to get to where he is now.
The captain finally realizes that the guy
he thought was a loser, is actually the most
dangerous enemy he has ever had. Currently, Luke’s
former partner Alex is the mayor’s boyfriend who
has gone corrupt like him. When the mayor is
informed about Mei and Luke being together,
he gets nervous. It is almost as if he knows
something about the safe and the combination
on it. In the meantime, Mei is brought back
to the leader Han who inquires if she told
the combination to anyone. She lies and insists
that she pretended not to understand English.
Chang calls Alex and tells him that they have
the girl so they can continue the meeting.
It is then revealed that the people the Chinese
mafia was trying to do business with are the mayor
and his boyfriend Alex. They are trading the
unknown contents of their respective safes.
Next, Luke arrives at the Casino where he
finds the Russian gangsters. He ambushes all of
Vassily’s henchmen and takes him hostage, planning
to use him to threaten the Russian leader Emile.
He calls Emile and asks him about the contents
of the safe in exchange for his son’s life.
Emile discloses that the safe with the Chinese
gangsters has thirty million dollars in it,
while the safe with the mayor has something that
is worth the aforementioned money. The parties
were about to trade using the little girl but
the Russians stepped in and destroyed the plan.
However, now that the Chinese have Mei,
the plan is back on track. Chang goes
to meet Alex and exchange the codes.
Now, the only way for Luke to save the girl
is by getting the thirty million dollars from the
Chinese mafia before the trade takes place. But,
he cannot do it on his own because the safe is
hidden deep in Chinatown and protected by the
most dangerous ones of the Chinese gangsters. So,
he asks for help from his former cop colleagues.
They agree to help, but only because of the money.
The group then walks into the hideout and starts
a shootout. On the way, several gangsters and
cops die. When they finally reach the locker,
Luke betrays the cops and shoots them dead,
except the captain, who he holds hostage alongside
Vassily. He also takes the money from the safe
and makes his way to the mayor’s office.
On his way, he calls Alex and asks him what is
in the second safe. Because Luke has the money,
Alex is bound to do everything he asks. He reveals
the second safe belongs to the mayor, containing
a disc with data on every crime syndicate in New
York. The mayor wanted to sell it to the Chinese,
take the thirty million and let the gangs deal
with what they had to. Alex was about to hold
the deal with Chang but since the money has
already been stolen, he tries to return to meet
Luke instead. But, Luke orders him to bring Mei
along because she is an important asset. Alex
follows the orders, kills Chang and his henchmen,
and drives to meet Luke along with the girl.
In the following scene, Luke breaks into
the Mayor’s office and asks him for the
contents of the second safe. Although
the mayor is reluctant, he has no choice
but to hand Luke a disc with the data on every
crime syndicate in New York. Luke knocks him out
and returns to meet Alex like promised.
With both the money and the information,
he is the most powerful one in the game
but Alex has something more special;
Mei. When the two finally meet to exchange Mei
for the money, Luke refuses to cooperate, instead
suggesting that they settle it with a fight.
Alex gets ready but is shot in the leg by Mei.
Taking the opportunity, Luke kills him with ease.
He and Mei are finally free with the money and the
disc that they can use for protection. For Mei’s
safety, Luke lets the captain free with fifty
thousand dollars as compensation for his troubles.
He also lets Vassily go, so the Russians wouldn’t
come after them. Then, there is the Chinese mafia
leader Han who got his money and Mei stolen from
him. Luke sends him all of the remaining money
so he wouldn’t try to look for Mei anymore.
At last, he hides several copies of the disc
throughout the city. In case someone tries to harm
them, they can use the drive as a way to blackmail
some powerful people. In the last scene, Mei and
Luke drive to Seattle to start a new life.
Subscribe for more videos like this,
turn on the notification, and leave a like to help
the channel out. Thanks for watching.